Ian can rake a lawn and bag the leaves
in 5 hours keiondre can rake the same
lawn and bag the leaves in 3 hours in 3
hours working together how long would it
take them to rake the lawn and bag the
leaves so the best way to think about
this is think about how many bags per
hour each of them can do and then we
could add the number of bags per hour
they could produce and then use that to
figure out how many hours per bag so
this piece of information
Ian can rake a lawn and bag leaves in
five hours so Ian is five hours five
hours per bag or you could view this if
we invert it as 1/5 of a bag 1/5 of a
bag per hour or one bag every five hours
this and this is saying the exact same
thing we can do the same thing for
keiondre for kyandre kyandre keiondre
and his or her case i'm not sure whether
keiondre is a boy or girl's name he well
I'll say she she'll she'll take 3 hours
per bag so it's 3 hours per bag or
that's another way of saying she can do
she can do if you invert this you could
1/3 of a bag per hour 1/3 of a bag per
hour because U is 3 hours per one bag
you invert it you get one bag per three
hours one bag for three hours this is
five hours per one bag same thing is one
bag for five hours you're just inverting
the ratio not really changing the
information now what's their combined
rate well Ian can do 1/5 1/5 of a bag
per hour and kyandre keiondre can do 1/3
of a bag per hour so what is this going
to be equal to well we find a common
denominator here common least common
multiple of 5 and 3 is 15 let's put it
over 15 so 1/5
is the same thing as 315th of a bag per
hour want to keep the unit's here bag
per hour and then 1/3 is the same thing
as 5 over 15 bags per hour so when you
add them you get three plus five is
eight so this is equal to 8 over 15 bags
per hour when I say bag I mean all the
stuff rake lawn and bag the whole tasks
per hour 8 15 of a task per hour so
working together how long would it take
them to rake the lawn and bag the leaves
well this is how many of these of the
bagging they can do per hour you can
invert this so if you invert that you
get this is equal to this is equal to 15
over 8 hours 15 over 8 hours per bag 15
over 8 hours per bag or if we want to
write this as a mixed number this is
equal to 1 and 7/8 hours hours per bag 1
let me write it like this hours 1 & 7 8
hours per bag and if we really want to
get a sense of what 7/8 is in terms of
hours we can multiply it by minutes so 7
8 hours times 60 minutes per hour and
let's see what we can do here 60 and 8
are both divisible by 4 8 divided by 4
is 260 divided by 4 is 15 7 times 15 is
C 7 times 10 is 70 plus 35 is 105 so
this is equal to 105 over 2 minutes
which is equal to what 52 point 5
minutes 52 point 5 minutes so as a
combined effort it will take them it
will take them 1 hour 1 hour and 52
point 5 minutes to do it together and
we're done